Nos dicen que: "Una fábrica produce juguetes
que se venden a $10 [dólares] por pieza. La
fábrica tiene 40 trabajadores y
cada uno produce 25 juguetes al
día. La fábrica abre 5 días a la
semana. ¿Cuál es el valor total
de los juguetes que la fábrica produce
en un día?" Pausa el video e inténtalo.
Muy bien, pensemos en lo que pasa en un día,
incluso antes de ver toda esta información.
Si encontramos el valor por juguete y lo
multiplicamos por el número de juguetes
producidos en un día -por el número de juguetes
producidos en un día-, entonces obtendremos
el valor total. Así que veamos si nos dan esta
información. Para encontrar el valor por juguete,
nos dicen "Una fábrica produce juguetes
que se venden a $10 [dólares] por pieza",
entonces podemos escribirlo de
esta forma: 10 dólares / juguete.
Ahora, también nos dan la información que
necesitamos para encontrar el número de juguetes
que se producen en un día: tiene 40 trabajadores
y cada uno de ellos produce 25 juguetes en un día,
entonces la cantidad total que la fábrica produce
en un día será 40 trabajadores • 25 juguetes /
trabajador. Ahora bien, podríamos decir: 25
juguetes por trabajador por día, pero esto
haría nuestras unidades un poco más complicadas,
o bien simplemente podemos dar por hecho que toda
esta expresión que estamos creando se refiere a un
solo día. Entonces, el valor total de los juguetes
producidos en un día será el producto de todo
esto. Podemos ver que las unidades coinciden -para
sentirnos seguros de que vamos en la dirección
correcta-, los juguetes en el denominador se
cancelan con los juguetes en el numerador, después
al multiplicar los trabajadores quedarán en el
numerador, mientras que estos otros están en
el denominador, por lo tanto, los trabajadores
se cancelan, así sólo nos quedaremos con 10 •
40 • 25, y queremos la respuesta en dólares.
Vamos bien. Así que esto será igual a 10 • 40 es
400, 400 • 25 será, bueno, esto es 4 • 25 • 100,
esto es 100 • 100 lo que es 10,000; y las unidades
son los dólares, 10,000 dólares. Ahora bien,
podrás decir "Oye, espera, no hemos usado toda la
información", y eso es cierto, no hemos usado el
dato que nos dice que la fábrica abre 5 días a la
semana; pero no necesitamos usar esa información,
nos hubiera sido útil si nos preguntaran "¿cuál
es el valor total de los juguetes que la fábrica
produce en una semana?", entonces responderíamos
que si el valor total por día es de 10,000 dólares
o podríamos escribirlo de esta forma, 10,000
dólares / día, y multiplicáramos esto por 5 días
a la semana, esto nos daría el valor total de
la producción en una semana. Pero esto no es lo
que nos preguntan, por lo que no necesitamos esa
información, y, por lo tanto, no tenemos que hacer
este último paso, esta es simplemente información
adicional, probablemente para distraerte un poco.